good morning so today we start the Bible
which will be the final unit before the
semester break hopefully this will be
the most interesting section we do it's
certainly the most important because the
Bible is the most important book uh ever
and it is driving a lot it has driven a
lot of history it's driving a lot of
history today so if you want to fully
understand the conflict in the Middle
East what's happening between Israel and
Iran uh what's happening in Palestine
you cannot do so without a full
understanding of the Bible at the same
time the Bible is um because it's so
important the ideas around it are very
controversial there are billions of
people around the world who believe the
Bible is the word of God it's Holy
Scripture every word in the Bible comes
to us from the Divine uh the Divinity
himself and obviously that's not what I
believe um more so I'm going to make
arguments in this class that go against
not only the traditional understanding
of the Bible but also the mainstream
academic understanding of the
Bible so um to be
fair uh to you um I want you to be very
skeptical of what I say okay come to
class with doubting my authority
doubting uh my understanding of the
Bible okay so feel free to challenge me
and I want you to challenge me uh
because what I will say in this class um
is will be extremely controversial okay
so let me give you a brief introduction
to the Bible um and then I'll explain
some of the history behind the Bible
okay and this overview is going to be
very broad very general but it will help
structure the AR of the Bible for the
next few classes okay all right so the
Bible the Bible is Greek for books and
it really means Library so the first
thing you need to understand is the
Bible it's a collection of different
works by many different authors so
there's no worldview or consistency or
continuity in the
Bible you can find whatever you want in
the Bible because it's it's such a it's
a library it's a huge
collection um of ideas there's about
2,000 pages okay so there's very few
people who actually read the Bible in
its entirity there are people who might
read certain sections of the Bible okay
but most people will only will receive
the understanding of the Bible from
authorities like priests or rabbis okay
um the bi the Bible itself is divided
into two major sections the first
section is what we call the Hebrew
Bible and so this was originally written
in Hebrew and this was this is the major
this is the book of the Jews okay what
do the Jews believe they believe in the
Hebrew Bible the Hebrew Bible itself is
divided into three major sections
the first is uh so uh so the Hebrew term
for the Bible is the tanak okay so you
may hear hear some people say the tanak
it just means the Hebrew Bible okay the
tanak is
TN K and this this is uh the Hebrew term
for certain ideas uh the T stands for
Torah or
teachings so this is the
laws of the Jewish tradition
okay for example The Ten Commandments
right second is n which means
prophets or uh and the prophets it
themselves are divided to minor and
major so in Rome um the people who are
most admire are the generals right
Julius Caesar Pompei in Greece the
people who are most am are The Poets
Homer and the
playwrights in the Jewish tradition the
people who are most admired are the
prophets uh these individuals who speak
the truth of God they're social critics
and there are people who challenge the
uh authority of the kings in order to
promote um the laws and teachings of God
okay does that make sense the prophets
are the the people who are most admired
in the Jewish tradition and the third r
k is writings so basically things that
don't really belong in teachings and
Prophets but which have some cultural or
religious significance to the Jewish
people okay so this is the Hebrew Bible
and then we get to the new testament
which is something that only Christians
believe all right so Jewish people do
not accept anything in the New Testament
the New Testament
calls the Hebrew Bible the Old
Testament okay why because the Old
Testament is the promise of
Salvation right the promise of Jesus
Christ the New Testament is the
Deliverance or the Fulfillment of This
Promise in Jesus Christ okay it's a
coming and the work of Jesus Christ New
Testament itself is dived to many
different works it's a lot it's a lot um
smaller than the Old Testament so there
are the
gospels the gospels is Greek for the um
good word and the good news is that
Jesus is on Earth and he's here to
Deliver us from our sins and our
suffering uh there's
letters uh mainly by someone named Paul
and these are the work of Jesus apostles
um after the death of Jesus they go
around the world they promote the Gospel
of Jesus the the good news okay and this
is about what they do and then there's
something called there's some other
books as well but the major one is
called re
Revelation um which is about the end of
the world and it's the idea of the
second coming how even though Jesus Is
Dead um he will return and he will bring
peace Eternal peace to the world
now from the Bible in interpretation of
the Bible comes the
Quran and this is a basis for Islam okay
So eventually we'll do all three the
Hebrew Bible the New Testament and the
Quran we'll start with the um Old
Testament the Hebrew Bible
okay um
so the Old Testament the Hebrew Bible is
what we will start with and to do so I
will have to teach you a lot of history
and this history will be extremely broad
okay but over time I will be more
precise I will go into specific details
about this history in order for you to
better understand the Bible okay um
there were three ideas about the Hebrew
Bible that Jews
believe the Jews today believe which are
not true okay the first idea is the
Hebrew Bible the Jewish religion has
always been
monotheistic meaning the Jews have
always believed in one God his name is
Yahweh and he is the god of the Jews
since Abraham who is the patriarch of
all Jewish people okay that's what Jews
believe I will show you this is not true
in the
beginning Jewish people like everyone
else was uh were
polytheistic okay monotheistic is a
modern idea that has been
retroactively um put back into Jewish
history okay so that's the first myth
that I will correct the second myth that
I correct
is that Jewish history or the Jewish
religion has been
continuous for at least 3,000 years
possibly 4,000
years okay and what I will show you is
that's not
true in so there have been many major
changes to the
religion and these changes are so
drastic that you can argue these are
very different people okay so um the
Israelites the people who the religion
are very different from the people we
call Jews today and I will show you why
in next few classes okay that's that's
one really important idea you need to
understand the history of the Israelites
and the Jewish people are not
continuous all
right okay does that make
sense okay any any any questions so far
are you guys following along
okay
um um yeah so and the last idea
is the Bible or the Hebrew Bible it's a
historical
record and what I will show you is um
we've been trying for at least 300 years
20 years to to prove that the Bible is
hisorical record okay there are
archaeologist who spent fortunes entire
lifetimes looking for things like Noah's
Ark looking for people like
Moses can't find them okay and this
tells us pretty conclusively that the
Bible is not a historical record it is a
work of our
imagination okay it is it is a literary
work now it's a very powerful literary
work and that's what explains
um its
relevance and its um Power today okay
I'll explain why it's powerful but I
want you to remember it's not historical
work it is a literary work it's a work
of our Collective
imagination all right okay now I'm going
to talk a little about the broad history
of the Israelite people okay um so in
the Bible what it tells you is maybe
about 2000
in uh BCE there's a man named Abraham
and he's a from the city of uh uh Eric
okay in Mesopotamia or is it ER okay
it's it's one of the two
sorry um and then God
Yahweh thought yah Abraham was the best
man in the world so God Yahweh made a
covenant with Abraham and said you are
are the most righteous and dignified man
I've ever seen in the world and I will
make you a father of a new nation called
Israel okay and these people will become
eventually the Israelites and the
goodest King of the Israelites is named
David and then David and then God says
to David David you are the greatest man
I've ever seen I love you as you love me
therefore I will make your house the
House of David
Eternal okay you the House of David will
ring over Israel for all eternity I will
make Israel into the mightiest of
Nations so that is what it says in the
Bible the historical record is a lot
more complicated all right so let's
start in the year
BC and this is towards the end of the
Bronze Age right we're about to enter
the Bron age collapse which last about
for 100 years at this time let's look at
the world issue is is in a place called
The
Levant and the Levant has always been
important because as we discussed in
previous classes lavant was one of the
first centers of agriculture culture so
Jericho is in the
Levant but it's also important because
the Levant is where three major
civilizations and Empires meet okay they
are the crossroads or the Nexus of
Empire these three Empires are Egypt
which again for most of its human
history has been the wealthiest and the
most powerful Nation okay over here is
Mesopotamia
which is the creative civilization this
is where um human civilization first
developed mathematics writing
astronomy architecture okay and up here
are the high ties or
Anatolia and Anatolia again is extremely
wealthy so the lavad is sort of
sandwiched between three extremely
aggressive
wealthy um and Powerful Nation
that that are extremely Advanced and
sophisticated so the
lant
um has always been a
colony of either Egypt or Anatolia okay
very it's it it's not been very
independent for very long and it can't
be because it's at the edge of
Empire but because of its position okay
the leavon is what we call a nothing po
or a meeting
place so every culture every language
every religion that was imaginable at
this time met in the Levant
okay mainly for trade purposes right
because again Egypt and mesop are
extremely wealthy from the lant you can
go across the Mediterranean into all of
Europe and into Northern Africa okay so
the lavant was really the center of the
world
for most of its history and so it was a
meeting place mainly for
traitors right um at this time uh lavant
was divided into different sections a
province called canine was a province of
Egypt and canine was special to Egypt
because the Egyptians loved two things
they loved wine they loved olive oil and
the Levant was very good at um
harvesting both wine good wine and and
olive oil so um but the Egyptians didn't
really like to go outside Egypt so the
people administrating the lavant were
local Elites tied to Egypt but also
foreign
mercenaries and these four mercenaries
were from as far as Greece okay and we
know this because we've discovered um
Greek pottery that dates back to this
period these four mer Mercenaries would
then inter Mar with a local woman
because as you can imagine these are
young uh
males
okay you also had lots of
Nomads living in the lavant because of
Arabia
right okay lots of nomad people we call
the
bans you also had people living in the
hills of the lon uh the Hill People then
you have these
cities okay the um the
Canaanites you also had Believe It or
Not Egyptian priests living in this area
why would they live in this area well
because they had a certain
religion that was considered her
heretical or controversial in Egypt so
they had to leave to practice their
religion or maybe they were priests who
got into a political struggle and as
such they were exile to the lant okay so
does that make sense the Levant it's not
at this point a nation at this point
it's really a meeting place a Melting
Pot of cultures languages and religions
it's as diverse as can be and
historically this has always been the
case right
then what happened of
course um is the Bron AG collapse the
thing about the Bron collapse is you
have this massive migration of people
looking for
food right these called the sea peoples
they're basically Pirates and this and
like there are these massive waves of
sea people
attacking the Hittites attacking the
lavant and attacking Egypt and again
these are like refugees
okay this is a forc
migration and they're trying to feed
their
families they basically overrun the high
ties they destroy the cities of the
lavant and they're they almost destroy
Egypt but egyp because it's so wealthy
it's able to hold off the sea people
eventually what happens is the ca people
and Egypt come to an agreement and say
listen stop attacking us and we'll you
land in the lavant you can settle down
there you can go your own food you can
feed your families okay and this place
is what we
call
philistia and this is and these people
Philistines so these are
basically um sea the sea peoples mainly
Greek actually there are a lot of Greeks
among the
Philistines but this creates a problem
for every once in the lant because now
you have a foreign mess uh sorry you
have a foreign presence that is very
aggressive and
expansionist okay so now the people the
lavant need to come together and F off
this threat from the Philistines they
also have these neighbors as well these
other cultures that keep on attacking
them okay so these are extremely diverse
people and so what they agreed to do is
elect a king to lead them in war against
the
Philistines and this person is named
Saul King
Saul all right and King sa is a very
good King he's a very good military
leader he's helping the people in the
Lavon fend off the Philistines and
aggressive neighbors okay so this is a
milit military Alliance
King
Saul um employs a lot of mercenaries and
one of these mercenaries is named
David
David David is an
extremely capable
charismatic Soldier Who develops a
following David as you can imagine
because he's very charismatic is also
very ambitious and eventually he has a
falling out with Saul okay David is
Saul's best General best soldier but
David is too ambitious and so sort of
suspects David so what David does is he
runs off and joins the
Philistines okay he's not fighting for
the Philistines what's really important
for us to understand and I know it's a
hard concept okay but borders and
alliances and allegiances are extremely
fluid at this time if it benefits me
I'll be I'll fight for you but if it
doesn't benefit me then I'll betray you
okay there are different factions within
all
alliances okay so the Philistines are
divided among different ethnic groups
the the people in the lavant are divided
into different political factions you
know you have these Hill people have
have these Nomads you have um these
foreign missionaries and they're
fighting for different reasons so the
the alliance are always shifting okay so
David um goes off and fights for the
Philistines King Saul and his sons are
eventually killed in battle and David
sees a political opening so he
turns back into Levant and he starts to
politically maneuver to be the new
king okay and um his power his power
power base is in a place called habran
or in South um the lont but the house of
Saul is still
around and so there's a civil war now
going on and eventually David
triumphs and then David's able to unite
these people and he creates a new nation
called
Israel all
right and then Israel is able under
David's leadership is able
to um basically
um put down any aggressions from its
neighbors and they're able to build an
Empire a small Empire okay nowhere near
Egypt but it's an
Empire all
right so this is what we know from the
archaological
record but David is so
charismatic that when he dies his son
Solomon is not able to hold the empire
together so uh what happens is
Israel divides into the northern
kingdom and
Judah which is where the House of David
is okay now again the Levant is a very
important strategic location so as these
Empires major Empires start to
consolidate the power
they want to take over the lant okay so
who so the Assyrian Empire comes in and
destroys the northern kingdom and then
eventually the Babylonian
Empire will come in and Destroy
Judah okay the B the Babylonians will
take the Israel Elite Bas basically the
royalty and force them to go to Babylon
where they will be H as hostages or
captives
eventually what will happen next is the
Persian
Empire will
come and defeat
Babylon and what they do next is very
interesting they decide they will
release these Israelite Elite H have
them return to Jerusalem and Israel and
have them govern the
lant based
on to and have them govern the Lan okay
does that make sense and it is only at
this point that we get the term
Jews okay this is a Persian idea the
Jews before they called the
Israelites and this about 500 BC okay
500 BC and now we have a radical
departure from
the tradition okay and so I'll explain
three major
differences and then I'll explain I'll
go into detail about these differences
in future classes okay the first major
difference
is Israel uh under Israelites it's a
very it's a
polytheistic
religion they don't they have one God
Yahweh but Yahweh but they also have a
Pantheon of Gods which is the same which
is true for every other religion right
there's a Pantheon of gods Yahweh is at
the top but they also celebrate other
gods like uh ba and asur okay we know
because they're written down in the
Bible so we know at this point Israel is
still a polytheistic
religion but after the Persian um but
after the Persian Empire returns them to
judism they became a
monotheistic uh religion or the
beginnings of a monotheistic religion
why
because when the when the Jews are
released from ctivity by the Persians
their
religion merges with that of the Persian
religion called zor aism and zorin ism
is a dualistic religion okay meaning
there's good and
evil so that's the first major
difference the at the beginning the
Bible was very much a polytheistic
religion and then
after uh the Israelites became the Jews
it
became M monotheistic
okay second big difference is this
second big difference is during this
time the people with the power in Israel
were the Kings okay the
monarchy but
after uh the but
after um 500
BC the Jews decided they don't want any
Kings and the don't have Kings because
the overlords are the Persians right so
the cent of power became the
priesthood okay the
priests the people with the absolute
Authority are the priests not the Kings
there are Kings but the kings are are
not subservient to the priests who speak
on behalf of
Yahweh okay because now it's a
monotheistic religion
and then there's one other difference
the the other difference is remember at
this point they're poly polytheistic and
they're kings okay which means they are
tolerant they're welcoming of other
religions right because you're
polytheistic but also as kings you need
to establish diplomatic alliances with
other countries or different religions
right so when you
marry uh someone uh from another
political Dynasty you also are marrying
into that religion does that make sense
so Israel under the Kings is a very
tolerant religion but if you're run by
priests right you become
intolerant because you insist that your
religion is the
best
okay and that's why after the Persians
lost control and the Greeks came in to
the vant uh this is the the saluan
Empire okay the Jews rebelled against
the Greeks because the Greeks were
polytheistic and the Jews consider
themselves monotheistic okay they
refused to acknowledge the culture and
the religion of the Greeks and then
things are really bad when the Romans
came in okay does that make
sense okay so this is the history
of the Jewish people up until the birth
of Jesus
okay any questions so far you guys
understand what's
happening how did Theon
collapse excuse me how did Theon AG
collap okay um so how did the bronch age
collapse okay we talked about this okay
okay we don't know why collapse the um
mainstream economic understanding is it
was a Perfecto it was a perfect storm of
several factors including climate change
including um civil unrest including
natural disaster like
earthquakes okay including um
competition among
Empires what's important to understand
is when we talk about bage
collapse it we're really talking about
about
basically this area if you go east to
Mesopotamia where the Neo sorry where
the Assyrian and the Babylonians are
they're
fine okay and it's BR collapse that
allow the syrians and the Babylonians to
eventually become world
powers so um the Bron collapse was not a
global phenomenon it was a localized
phenomenon to the Mediterranean okay but
why the Bron collapse is important is
because the bran claps will give us
Greek civilization Homer and Plato okay
it will also give us the Bible right
because if you if you look at this
history Israel would not have come into
being without the branchage
collapse Egypt or the high ties would
continue to control the
lant all right and it's important to
understand the Greeks and the Bible are
the basis the two fundamental pillars of
Western Civilization you understand
that's why westerners are so fascinated
by the branch AG collapse because in
their minds the branch AG collapse is
part of God's divine plan or design to
create Classical Greece and the is in
the nation of Israel so that his vision
for the world can be achieved through
Jesus okay
yep yeah that's fine
yeah okay so that's a good question so
the argument I'm trying to make up make
make to you is the Bible says Abraham is
a patriarch of the
Israelites but the historical record the
AR the AR Aral record is we be have
evidence of David we have abely no
evidence of anything before David
okay um
so I think David is a founder of the
nation of Israel and not Abraham next
class I I will explain to you why they
constructed this mythology okay
all right but I but first I want to give
you a broad overview all right next
class I will explain to you where these
ideas Abraham and Moses came from it'll
make sense when I when I explain it to
you okay but you guys do you guys have
any more questions before I go on yeah
can you clarify on
how Isel
ReliOn okay right okay okay
so
um uh what happened with during the
Persian period right okay so at this
point um the religion of Israel is no
different from the local areas it's part
it's it's a it's a polytheistic religion
with a pentagon of gods okay and maybe
yahweh's at the top or maybe Yahweh is
co-equal okay we don't know and at this
point there are many Divergent
religions okay
but what happens is Babylon conquers
Jerusalem and then the Jews are sent in
Exile so now the religion is sent
overseas and it's the religion is
detached from the culture and the people
does that make sense and what we know is
when you do that when you when you
detach the religion and you put it into
a place that has no interactions with
the local people in the culture it
becomes much
more uh fanatical much it becomes much
more focused and fanatical okay do you
understand okay do do you understand
because if it's in Israel and they
different cultures the religion has to
be tolerant and um please different
factions among the people okay does that
make sense but once this religion goes
off to Babylon it's now divorced from
the people from local reality so the
elite can design in a way that they
think is most appropriate and we call
that
fanatical does that make sense so an
example of this okay um it's a bad
analogy but but maybe this will help you
right now you're not sure what it means
to be Chinese okay you're Chinese but
Chinese in China it's a very fluid uh
very uh diverse
identity when you go off to
America
right then you have much C more concrete
much more clear understanding of what it
means to be Chinese your Chinese
identity becomes much more formed does
that make sense okay the same thing with
religion within Israel itself the
religion is constantly changing it's
very
fluid but when they're off to Babylon
they have to use religion to survive as
a people as an identity and so it
becomes much more um formed okay much
more concrete does that make
sense and then what happens is as
it's now that's much more
concrete it now interacts with zor
asianism which is the religion of the
Persians and and at this point the
religion
becomes um basically what it is today
okay um so I I'm sorry I don't I I don't
think I've explained this clearly
clearly to you but I want to wait until
we get to this period okay right now
right now I'm just giving you like a
broad overview okay any more questions
before I begin before I
continue all right now I want to talk
about the Bible okay
because the
Bible is the mythology it's a collective
memory of the Israelites
okay and so I'm I'm going to discuss why
the Bible was first created in this
class and what what I will explain to
you is the Bible was first created in
order to explain and just justify and
create legitimacy for David okay this
what we call an
apology and this is a very common
practice the idea is this most Kings
every King obtains power
through
um really nefarious means okay they
either kill a lot of people to obtain
power or maybe the younger brother kills
the older brother to usurp the throne
okay usually kingship
requires um
ruthlessness but the problem is when
you're ruthless you have a legitimacy
problem right so the way that most Kings
resolve this issue is by
sponsoring
writings or an apology to explain why he
or she is king and the answer usually is
because God will it so because I have no
choice in the matter I'm not ambitious I
was not at all ambitious but the
circumstance is forced my hand to save
my people to do God's work I had to kill
my brother I had to kill my enemies even
though I myself am not a violent person
okay that's usually how the apology goes
okay so
remember back at this point the very
idea of writing it is new it's a new
technology but it's also a very
expensive technology meaning you need to
buy the materials okay which which are
rare but you also need the people to be
able to write okay and they're also Al
very expensive and you basically needed
to be able to support a team of scribes
to create any work of fiction so writing
back then is like movie making today
okay it's a very expensive um Endeavor
that was usually sponsored by the king
in order to
justify uh or explain why he is King in
order to create
legitimacy does that make
sense so the Bible was created first as
an apology for
David and explains why the house of
House of David is now in charge of
Israel but as we
discussed
okay eventually the House of David
Israel divides into two
Nations now the House of David the Bible
goes with the house with how Judah okay
to to
Judah but the northern kingdom now needs
his own mythology its own Bible right
and so a second Bible was
created the people who are in charge of
the Bible uh the priest class are
interested in promoting their
own um interests mainly in the points of
ritual it does that make sense like what
are rituals why do we need them why are
priests important then you have um
people at this point in the Babylon
captivity looking back at the history of
Israel and trying to figure out why the
House of David collapsed and their
answer is because the Israelites refus
to follow the will of God because the
Israelites became polytheistic or they
became immoral okay does that make sense
in other words the Bible at this point
are divided into like four major
factions or
schools okay the school that supports
the House of David the legitimacy of the
House of David is called the J school
okay the J school don't worry about this
I'll explain to you next class what
these things mean the people who support
the northern kingdom as legitimate House
of Israel is called the E School
e the school school that supports the uh
Power of the priest obviously call the P
school okay for
priests and then the school that tries
to go back in history and examine why
Israel uh
fail um and which believe it's because
the Israelites betrayed God this these
people are what we call the D score okay
the D
score so EGP and d and these are just
four of the major schools there are
other schools as well all right and so
at this point the Bible was divided into
like four major schools or
documents controlled by different
factions when the
Persians take over okay they insisted
you need one religion guys you need one
document and so all four were put
together to create the Bible but the way
the way they did it was very interesting
all they did was just put them put them
together okay do you understand
so you have so if you read the Bible
it's like a b c d a b c d okay so one
line is from the e school the next line
is from the J School the other line is
from the P school it's very confusing to
read if you don't understand this
history it is impossible for you to read
the Bible I'm not sure if you tried to
read the Bible it's not readable okay so
why would they do this why would they
just put all four texts together without
major editing or revisions why do you
guys
know why would they do that it's very I
mean they just made a complete mess of
the Bible but why would they do
that okay okay so let me explain the
first major reason is most people didn't
read or write back then so the Bible
itself didn't really matter What
mattered was the oral explanation of the
Bible controlled by the priest class
does it make sense the people didn't
read the Bible so how the Bible was
actually written was not that important
it was important um for the priest to
have access to the Bible okay but the
people didn't actually read the Bible
that's the first reason the second more
important reason is because the the
Bible is
political real
estate and I want you to remember this
idea okay this the most valuable
political real estate in the world
everyone wants to be in the Bible
because to be in the Bible gives you
legitimacy it gives you power right so
if you're a king you have four sons who
all want to be king well your best
solution is to divide the kingdom among
the four Sons right same with the Bible
you have four extremely powerful schools
and Bal factions so the be the best way
to resolve the issue is just to say
listen we'll put you all in the Bible
together
okay like and you you when you merge
them it's a lot easier than if you just
try to do it um by order okay like e
scho goes first first and J school then
P school then D school okay they just
put them all
together does that make sense okay so
this is a very important idea the Bible
is the most is the most valuable
political real estate in the world
everyone wants to be in there and what
ideas are you can find in there will
ultimately shape human
history okay any questions so far before
I before I
continue all right so the last thing I
want to talk about
today is the apology of David which is
the beginning of the
Bible okay um
so when kings come to power they have
three major problems right the first
major problem is
legitimacy what gives you the right to
be
king okay second problem is the idea of
identity and this is a huge problem for
the Israelites because Israelites it's a
multicultural entity you have people
speaking different languages different
cultures they they practice different
cultures they practice different
religions so now you need to create an
identity that everyone
accepts Okay the third thing
is
differentiation you need not only for
these people to get along but you need
them you need to get them to divorce
their former culture does that make
sense because you have Egyptian priests
in there you have to tell these Egyptian
priests you're now Israelites and you're
not Egyptian
anymore an example that we use for
this um is Augustus
Caesar and the writing of the
inad okay remember the inad it's a book
about a character named inas
and it provides political legitimacy to
August Caesar because Augustus Caesar is
a direct descendant of inas who is the
founder of
Rome also what the inat said
is a Caesar is the end point of Roman
history everything before August Caesar
led to him Aus Caesar is like the Jesus
of Rome okay he is the Salvation he's
Redemption
of Rome okay that's what the inas the
inad does okay second second thing about
the inad is it creates a new Roman
identity that's that focuses on piety
loyalty over Liberty remember the
problem uh fora Caesar was Romans in
like kings well now he's a king so how
do you get people to obey well you tell
them Piet is more important than Liberty
right the third idea is
the Indian remember it's anti- Greek the
problem for Rome at that time was Greek
culture was vast Superior to ran
culture and so a lot of Romans were
adopting Greek cultural practices like
Mark
Anthony and so uh the inad
said Greek culture is like the troan
horse if you let into your city Greek
culture will corrupt you and destroy Joy
you
okay so guess what guys every King has
to resolve all three issues okay
legitimacy identity and
differentiation and that's what David is
trying to do with the
Bible okay so let's so I'll give you
three
examples three stories from the Bible
that
illustrate um
David's quest for
legitimacy next class we will talk about
um identity and differentiation and how
the Bible achieves that okay but this
this class I want to focus on
legitimacy so now that David is
King a lot of people don't think he's
legitimate why because he
ruthlessly tried to user the Throne from
Saul right Saul is the king that
everyone picked or
elected and he was a good King he was
good at War he was someone that most
people um liked and David took stole the
th Throne from him okay so now what is
David's problem now that he has a
throne others will try to steal it from
him right you understand because if you
David are if you said the president if
you um steal the throne then others are
now empowered to steal the throne from
you as well okay so the first thing the
Bible does the apology for David does is
show us
David loved Soul he was not at all
ambitious he cared only for the
well-being of his King okay and so one
story that illustrates this there are
actually many many stories in the Bible
that does this but one story that
illustrates this is this so Saul thinks
David's trying to kill him so he's
chasing after David with his army okay
trying to kill David and his
followers one uh one day Saul is alone
in a cave praying to God for
deliverance David sees Saul alone and
and he sneaks up behind Saul then he
takes his sword and
cuts a piece of soul
uh clothing okay and then David
disappears sa leaves the cave and then
David rushes to him and says Saul my
king I beg of you give me a second let
me explain to you back then in the cave
I could have killed you this is a piece
of clothing to prove I could have killed
you but I didn't because I love you
because I'm loyal to you I would never
kill you and then Saul says oh this is
this is
proof that you were you never meant to
kill me okay and this is a story in the
Bible um obviously this story cannot be
true okay but this is what the Bible's
trying to do it's trying to first show
us that David is not all ambitious in
fact the entire apology of David is
focused on the lack of ambition of
David okay so that's the first story
let's look at the Second Story okay the
second story is
this soul is dead and his son who's a
young man um comes into the throne
there's a general named adner okay Abner
who was loyal to Saul but now that Saul
is dead and David is very popular among
the people adner sees the political
winds changing and Abner tries to align
himself with David So Abner writes a
long letter to David and saying
listen I will swear loyalty to you and
will end the civil war between the house
of Saul and the House of David you will
unite Israel and then David writes back
and says yeah come to my um come to me
we'll have I I'll give you a feast and
then we'll be
friends and so adner comes David gives
him a feast and then as adner
leaves he runs into um David's General
named joab
joab and joab and Abner go a long way
back okay they were friends they were
enemies Abner killed Jo
brother and in an act of anger
joab stabs adner to death okay Abner is
dead and once Abner is dead the house of
Saul basically gives up and David is
able to unite um
Israel okay that's the so in the
Bible David is so angry by this that he
curses job and he and he gives amner
uh great
funeral right because
David does not does not want to betray
his
friends why is this
story wrong
or completely made up it's not made up
but it's it's what we call spin
right
clearly adner and David had um a Feast
together and clearly joab killed Abner
but why is the Bible version of of of
this event wrong or incorrect it can't
be true you guys
know okay this is hard okay
but the reason is this if you're David
and you're King which person in the
world are you most afraid
of if you're the king there's a person
in this world you're most afraid of or
you're most suspicious of who is that
person
H Abner okay yeah he is suspicious of
Abner but in general you should be
suspicious of joab right because joab
has access to your army Abner is your
enemy but joab has access to your army
so if joab wants to betray you he could
okay so in other words because David is
most suspicious of joab if joab were
ever to act
independently then David would need to
kill him does that make sense and in
this circumstance joab acted
independently David told joab apner was
an honored guest and joab didn't
care he was angry about the death of his
brother and he kills Abner this cannot
possibly be true you understand joab had
to kill Abner because he was ordered to
by
David right now now why would David want
adner to be killed because in his mind
he thinks oh if Adar can can can betray
the house of Saul he can also betray the
House of David he is an ambitious
man and why would he think like
that why would David come to this
conclusion because he himself is like
that do you understand he he himself
betrayed Saul so he's very very very
careful or cautious about people who
betray their leaders
right Abner betrayed the house of Saul
and it was very likely that he would
betray David at some point as well and
so David had to have him
killed
right but he could not say this publicly
because if you if you were to say this
publicly then it would
show he in fact knew knew this because
he betrayed Soul does that make sense
the logic of this okay but you can see
how wonderful the spin is it's almost
impossible to see the truth from this
right if you're a person you know okay
um David uh um you know that job killed
Abner and you told the story you believe
the story it's just because Abner was
angry that he killed uh sorry it was it
it was just because job was angry he
killed Abner you believe that right when
you think about it it can't be true okay
now I'm GNA give you one more story and
this story is actually even harder to
figure out because of the
spin okay now that um David is king of
Israel Israel has many enemies so his
armies are always at War okay one day
David is
on the rooftop of his house so and this
is Israel is not a very rich place okay
so these these AR palaces they're just
houses okay and so David is strolling on
his rooftop and
across from him is a woman named BBA
bash
sheiba and she's bathing naked and David
is overcome with lust he's like I must
have this woman okay and he's King he
orders his servant to go get her she
comes they have
sex okay the problem is we have sex but
she gets pregnant okay the problem now
is but she was married to a man named
UA the he
Tite and Yu the hightide is one of
David's best soldiers and he's fighting
for David and Israel somewhere else so
David's like oh this is a problem
because
once yua comes home and he finds BBA has
a new child he's going to know it's not
his so either he's going to kill her or
he's gonna figure out it's David to come
kill him okay so David being very clever
has a solution to this he invites Ura
back home okay so UA comes home from the
war and UA thinks oh the King has called
for me therefore it's an emergency okay
so he rushes back and David meets Yura
at his house and David says listen Yura
you've been doing such a great
job um you're such a great Soldier
you're so loyal I want to give you a
vacation go home and be with your wife
and you is like uh my
king my comrades are dying they're
starving out in the battlefield I can
abandon them how can I find pleasure my
wife when my friends are are suffering I
refuse to go home I will not go home
until the battle is
won and David tries his best but he
can't convince Yura to go home so then
David tells UIA you're such a great
Soldier you're so loyal I'm so happy and
proud that you fight for me he gives you
a letter to his General uh joab okay and
the letter instructs joab to kill yua he
joab will send Yura with his soldiers
out in the battlefield and then at the
last minute Jo will recall his soldiers
leaving Jo by himself at this point the
enemies will swarm Uria and kill Yura
and that's what
happens and once yura is dead David
marries
basba and they have and they're about to
have a child together at this point
David is visited by a prophet named
Nathan and Nathan says to David I want
to ask you a question and David says
sure go ahead Nathan says let's imagine
there are two Shepherds there's a rich
shepherd with a 100 sheep and there's a
poor shepherd with two sheep there's a
traveler a foreign guest who comes in a
town and the rich Shepherd wants to
honor him with a feast the shepher the
rich Shepherd steals the poor man's
Shepherd to feed the traveler who's
going wrong and David says of course the
rich Shepherd is in the wrong he's
indignant he's angry How could a man be
so unrighteous as to steal another man's
sheep and then naan says you David are
the rich Shepherd you have violated
God's law you are the wrong and as
punishment God God will take away your
son or your child with basba and that's
what happens
and David is goes into mourning okay he
is distraught he's depressed he writes a
lot of
poetry okay so this is a very powerful
story and this is a story that has
captured
imagination of everyone for a thousand
years but it's complete spin
this is not what happened okay how do we
know okay first thing is
this Nathan says to David you have
stolen a man's Shepherd uh sorry you
have stolen a man's wife therefore you
in the wrong what's what's the problem
with this
logic what is if it's crime real
Crime Guys he killed you
right you understand you you forgotten
this fact he had Yura
killed that's the real crime he killed
Ura yeah he s with BBA that's bad but
it's much worse if you murder someone
okay so another question then
is why would he murder
Yura why not just talk to him honestly
and says Zia I'm sorry I love your
wife I I had sex with her I'm sorry why
did he why did David have have to have
have to get Thea killed what was Thea
killed yeah because the loyal the Army
is loyal to Ura
right so why would David fear Yura
because yura is is a popular Brave
Soldier just like
David and David used his popularity in
order to user the throne from Saul
right therefore David thinks Yura could
do the same thing to
me therefore I have to have to get him
killed in other words this BBA thing
must have come later to disguise the
fact that David killed Ura because he
feared ura's popularity does that make
sense right you see how clever this
story
is the historical truth must have been
David feared y
popularity and he need to get rid of
Yura so he can C this
plan and then after he killed UIA he
need he needed to explain to his army
okay who loved Ura why this happened and
then they was like oh because I fell in
love with his wife I couldn't control
myself I'm just a man okay God is God
I'm a man I'm a king I can't be God I
can't control my
emotions right does that make
sense
but the irony of this is
because David is working so hard to
disguise his
ruthlessness he's creating very powerful
literature he created very powerful
story that has captured the
imagination of readers for a long time
time and you think about it you think a
lot about the story it unleashes a lot
of ideas in you okay you have to ask
yourself what is man what is God are we
capable of controlling our emotions so
in other words this story is extremely
well
constructed that inspires you to imagine
your own
personal and
emotional and moral life
we call this
literature
right
so guys it's no coincidence that today
the Jewish people are the most creative
people in the world when you go to
America for University uh most of your
professors are Jewish most of the best
thinkers in the world are Jewish these
past 200 years there have been three
revolutionary thinkers Carl Marx
Albert Einstein and San Freud they're
all Jewish who are who are stepped who
are who have been raised in the Jewish
tradition of asking deep questions about
what it means to be
human does that make
sense okay any questions about this
okay that's a great question okay so the
question is why would people believe
this apology of of David and well the
answer is most most didn't believe the
apology of David okay most were very
clear about David's
Ambitions
but when you're
King you need
to impose your reality on others okay so
this is why this written
and so um it was written for people who
were part of David's political Coalition
do you understand his enemies wouldn't
believe this right but it was meant it
was basically meant to appease or
convince those who want to believe David
does that make sense okay Spin and it's
it's it happens today guys when you
watch the news it's spin right it's it's
the story of reality
and so most people will believe the
media right there are some people who
will never believe the media like I I
don't believe any anything the media
tells me whether it's Chinese Media or
American Media I I know a lot of history
to understand the media is is distorting
reality okay but uh most people will
will believe this because they have
absolutely no interest in not believing
it right David it's King if you don't
believe it then you have to then you
have to believe your king is a murderer
okay does that make
sense yeah yeah Echo what's the main
understanding of story oh yeah that's a
great question okay I yeah this is
really important what's the mainstream
understanding of the story so the
mainstream understanding of the story is
it has to be true why because it puts
David in a bad light do you
understand and it shows the genius of
David because
David is wrestling with his own Mor
reality David is being
honest right so the M understanding is
David is a poet
King he's a man who prays
constantly
and engages in a process of
self-reflection and that's what makes
David
great okay he's constantly praying to
God in fact the Bible just goes on
endlessly about this how David is
constantly in communication with God and
in this communication he's praying and
asking for light for for truth in his
own weaknesses okay to be delivered from
his failings as a
man and the Bish bisha story is
epanic um about this because why would a
man make this up
right well I've told you why but most
schols don't see that most schs think
okay well this basa story puts David in
the worst possible light therefore it
must be true and therefore it shows us
David is a PO King who is constantly
thinking about his own moral failings
and so he's an
inspiration to his people okay that's
the mainstream
understanding any other
questions
yep that's right
oh okay so um the question is if people
at that time were mainly
illiterate why was this written down or
how would they know the story okay
so um the idea is this first of all this
was written for the elite for the people
around David to know what story to tell
people does that make
sense okay this is so this was for
internal consumption
and this was to basically uh preserve
David's historical
Legacy so maybe 20 years from now when
everyone's dead when people who knew UIA
and basiba were dead well what what is
truth now the truth is what what's been
written down okay that that's why
they're saying history is written by the
writers right history is not written by
the winners history is written by the
writers right
okay does that make sense okay any more
questions okay great so next class uh we
will continue the the Hebrew Bible okay
because it starts off as an apology for
David but it evolves into a much larger
mythology right so that's next class